my sister what's she doing it I smoke
laughing Joe giving you this
turning them over Russia breathless
would it's one-way
standby don't make this up it's a proxy
war done we're all just pawns in this
you speak for yourself
and iboga yes sir
[Music]
but here's your's Intel's life whatever
you've got going on
Kordofan agent
Cory sticks captain
I know how this works captain what this
time they gave the deer to the Russians
if he's lucky looks like you saved the
free world again captain
nice idea allocated bark off slab any
toy soldier [ __ ] crazy yeah well
we're a little crazy on me
there's no right Alex affirmative sir
would you help recover finish what he
started
you're a good friend captain and the
worst enemy I'm sure but I do not cross
borders and invade I defend my people
here at home sometimes the best line of
defense so loud
plans personnel I see a militia thought
back to the carry out this mission
[Music]
I don't blame the terrorists good night
I knew I could trust you
he's my operation to destroy bar coughs
gassy I can provide you two blocks can
Iowa uncharged is on the pipeline
foreign Alex you'll get a detonator from
Nikolai rig the main furnace when the
charges are set give a safe distance
[Music]
shoes on members open Kate
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
you
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
Oh Josh the verb tonight that will start
of a chain reaction on the furnace the
rest Allah correct don't lose it
boy help us Marco we sustained in my
country it will not stand
what Stephen Nicolai
don't think twice and son genetic see on
the other side
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Roger what you'll never get away in time
I know
Farah listen to me
oh you listen to me because of this
poison my people have done something
worse than war I did not come this far
to turn back I'm not asking you to turn
back I'm asking you to give me the order
commander please I am NOT USB Oh
somebody needs to kill me and you can't
do both I've got an assignment on my
whole life this
give me the order what a freedom fighter
Alex your boy Lee Farah say the word
[Music]
plane to the pipeline now set sergeant
there are at least now I kept it at all
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Southwest look
[Music]
hey let's lead this way let's get this
done yes sir
[Music]
back of is Alex
[Music]
mother Esther would approve where to
Kazakhstan
[Music]
I should disown Barca much choice did
they he's dead
you took a big bite out of that problem
John for now well left unchecked it
won't be general Shepherd pulled the
files you asked for exactly is this
about I suppose for us we already have
loose ends
you know I will tie them I can
[Applause]
is your crew
Kyle recorded the gas you never said
anything
John what Savitch SAS sniper demolitions
goes by so why is Simon Reilly this
picture never I just need to know why
not you got a deal
what are you calling this task force one
for one